money one of the hardest things to talk
about in families 80% of children
eight-zero get to college having never
had a conversation with their parents
about money where it comes from how it's
earned
how it's spent what debt is you can't
just give your kids launch them into
their lives without giving them the
tools so I went to what I thought would
be the smartest people to talk to about
this Warren Buffett's bankers they
advise the wealthiest families in the
country and I thought they must know
more that can help my family turns out
that these wealthy families are making
even more mistakes and I walked away
from this conversation with a number of
takeaways takeaway number one show them
the money it's incredibly important to
talk to children about money at an
age-appropriate level but you need to
talk as Buffett's bankers said to me I
spoke to the richest woman in America
and she said it's a burden if I tell my
children how much money they have and he
said it's much more of a burden to
burden them with ignorance than to
burden them with the truth number to
actually try to limit the influence of
money after doing all this research in
our home we have chores we have
allowance we do not overlap the two
because if you do it turns out the kids
will do the chores just for the money
you get an allowance as part of being a
member of our family but sorry someone's
got to put the dishes in the dishwasher
someone's got to make their bed you're
part of the team you have to take care
of yourself and the last thing is let
them make mistakes Buffett's bankers
chided me when I told him we we're kind
of forcing our kids to put their money
into different pots spend save giveaway
etc he said let them decide for
themselves and I said but what if they
make a mistake what if they wanted to
buy something and they've spent all
their money on candy
what if they drive into a ditch and his
answer was one of my favorite quotes and
the secrets of happy families he said
it's much better to make a mistake with
a six dollar allowance than a $60,000 a
year's salary or a six million dollar
inheritance the point is when the kids
are young when the stakes are lower let
them make their own mistake
then you're there to pick them up you
don't want to get that call home when
they're 24 and suddenly they're in debt
and they've made bad decisions and
they're really in a hole let your kids
take more responsibility from a younger
age
the most common pitfalls I think that
parents made on the topic of money is
thinking that they're afraid to talk
about it that they don't want to be
honest and they also think that they're
not passing along their values guess
what you are if you're worried and you
have anxiety about money you're gonna
pass that anxiety on to your children if
you show them by contrast that you do
have worries but this is how you're
working it out that you're sitting down
with your spouse maybe with other family
members on a regular basis to talk about
money that's the lesson you want to
convey because if you're showing those
values the kids will pick them up also
to me it's part of the larger takeaway I
emerged from with this project I
occasionally lose my temper I
occasionally yell at my children and I
always thought I'm just a bad dad when
that happened I'm just an awful parent
because I'm showing them that I'm not
always in control what I've learned is
losing control is actually natural and
something kids need to see but show them
that when you do lose control that you
also regain it and solve the problem in
real time solve the problem in front of
them that's the message you want to give
them with and the same applies to money
if you're having a hard time we're gonna
buy a car next year and so already we're
not going to buy this thing this year or
we're gonna go on a less expensive
vacation so we can save money for a car
be open with your kids about it the
actual reason you'll pass on good